so today the try guys are taking a lie
detector test
if you ever pictured anyone at the
office do you think you're better than
other people because you have a great
marriage you ever wanted to [ __ ] any of
us the try guys are gonna interrogate
each other and see who are the liars and
how much we deeply secretly hate each
other right John we will I'm John I'm a
polygraph examiner I've tested over
8,000 people if I see one of them lying
I will let you know
God hates Liars and I hate liars all
right let's detect those lies they do
lie but it's only because they don't
want to hurt people's feelings
good morning Keith how we doing start
with the softball Keith do you like my
chest hair yes Keith his line I wouldn't
want it on myself do you ever think I
talk about my wife too much oh yeah
keith is telling the truth I mean yeah I
told ya do you have a really large mouth
yes
you ever wonder about how many big
things you can fit inside of it yeah
are those things sometimes penises for
comedies sake yeah for sexual sake
sometimes no pee fish line okay there's
good thing I'm nervous about my results
agree like I ain't never boys I do like
I lie a lot but if you ask me a direct
question I will give you a direct answer
porn Diddy if that is your real username
is there anything that you're afraid
we'll ask today no he's lying do you
like being single yeah
he's telling the truth sometimes it's
okay like I think they're their purse
you think you talk too much
have you ever stolen anything from one
of us other than a pen no he's telling
the truth
but I've definitely stolen where do they
go I'm a pretty bad liar I don't have a
problem telling the truth even if it
hurts do you think you have a problem
controlling your volume no he's lying
well I don't think it's a problem do you
think I'd make a good husband he's lying
can't get anything by you jack picture
this you can either save a school bus
full of nuns or your wife Ariel do you
murder the nuns and cold-blooded murder
those he's telling the truth it's an
easy question the nuns are typically
very old there at the end nobody likes
nuns Eugene I was I grew up Catholic I'm
not a fan of lying but I do have a lot
of Secrets all right good morning Eugene
how we feel and today Eugene do you
secretly think that Ned and his wife are
gonna get divorced someday no of course
give us he's lying I could have told you
that Zack to be fair I'm a child of
divorce so am I the only child of
divorce in the try guys yep yep there's
some stuff to your brains guys do you
believe in true love
No
he's telling the truth oh wow you
believe in ghosts
yes he's telling the truth
what yeah I would not have normally not
admit that but my mom potentially is
psychic so I found that out she was her
mother was weaned on the teat of the
town psychic because post Korean War
anyway a lot of women died of disease so
we had to use the psychic Eugene do you
think that's weird
no he's telling the truth well it is
Eugene have you ever thought about
replacing one of us in the try guys yes
he's telling the truth
we should have a black member right of
course yeah you ever made out with a
co-worker no he's lying yeah I could
tell that even without being hooked up
to a polygraph do you think that I'm bad
at karaoke yeah keith is telling the
truth do you think you're more handsome
than Keith yes he's telling the truth
you ever wanted to [ __ ] any of us no
he's lying
have you made out with two of our
coworkers no he's mine you know want to
[ __ ] me no telling the truth a boat full
of new born Italian babies or a boat
with your wife have you ever won and
[ __ ] me no telling the truth then we
already know who he wants to [ __ ] do you
think you're a better performer than the
rest of us yes
thief is telling the truth have you made
out with three of our coworkers he's
lying Bob can I have four
know who's telling the truth okay so
it's a three it's three do you think
you're funnier than the rest of us
yes peepers telling the truth turn on
the really picture do you kill the
Italian baby boat Ned
yes he's telling the truth yes I believe
in his love with her these scenarios
I don't know those babies Ned
you and Ariel are so cute together is
any of it just for show yeah sure he's
telling the truth
it's like Instagram sometimes you post
the photo that's like the cutest version
I don't need your explanation let's talk
about Becky Oh beautiful fiance Becky
you ready to get married yeah keith is
telling the truth follow up question
there Keith everyone knows you love
fried chicken if you had to give up
Fried Chicken for the rest of your life
in order to marry your fiance would you
do it yeah keith is telling the truth
Wow I'm so sorry is your hair the
product of all your insecurities yes
she's telling the truth
was the one thing people said was
attractive when I was young I didn't
even get that do you think you'll ever
get married yeah telling the truth then
why do you give me so much [ __ ] about it
do you ever want children yes
he's telling the truth you hated little
kiddies you think I'm ever gonna find
love
yeah teeth is lying Cherokee's eugene do
you know how much the three of us care
about you no telling the truth we gotta
be better about them hey Keith
do you like Ned's dog no what keith is
telling the truth I don't like any dog
do you like Eugene stone I do it's chief
is telling the truth then I'm know if
you noticed but uh medicine to the left
ear also has a wedding ring on do you
just assume that you have a better
marriage than most people you know he's
telling the truth you think you have a
better marriage than John I I assume so
yeah you know he's older marriages tend
to you know not get it's as good as they
get older but like I don't know
everybody does I'll kill you right here
John if you could save your wife for
that it's not full of orphans die would
you do it I'd kill her there you go out
of all the try guys he's your favorite
Keith
he's telling a curve which of the track
guys do you love Caitlin's telling the
truth who is your favorite out of the
other try guys Keith he's telling the
truth so which one of us
[Music]
Keef is telling the truth jumpy our body
I'm the battery do you think you're the
best tracker no he's telling the truth
but I do think I'm better than some of
you do you think you're the best
Tryg I know you're telling the truth Ned
do you think you're the best in the try
guys no he's lying
do you think you are the best try guy
yes
keith is telling the truth sorry you
have to have self-confidence so that was
great
I like being hooked up to machines yeah
I tried to lie several times and it
didn't really work I don't think I'm
self-absorbed but maybe I am huh
apparently I want to [ __ ] Zac which is
super gross well I just hope this makes
us better friends have you ever hooked
yourself up to one of these and just
like ask yourselves questions in the
mirror see what you truly believe it's
not a toy no everything's a toy if you
play with it
[Music]
do you think you can ever learn how to
answer a yes or no question with just
yes or no
here's the thing though is that there's
complexity right let's see question
coming out I feel like you know there's
a lot of shades of gray in the world
I'll kill you right